how is your life change between last
summer and now I started making the EP
which is the big thing
my signed with Universal and Island in
the UK in the US which was very amazing
but you may mess
that's single just dropped
tell us about it like what was the
inspiration behind it a story so if the
song is called last summer and it's
about me meeting like a kind of special
girl meeting some cool friends and
hanging out and having a great time then
just being kind of carefree being a kid
doing what I want to do what is the big
celebration for you and your family when
all this stuff that started happening
the day that I got assigned to you music
Canada but that was a celebration yeah
yeah there is like a like a whole
signing thing I got to keep the pen I
still have it when you hear about
someone getting signed to a major label
I don't know if your if your friends
know much about the music industry so
are they like whoa like are they going
insane about it so they're thinking like
now you're gonna be driving around in
like Lamborghini that's the baby yeah
yeah they're like oh you outside and
you're like famous now right oh my god
no but yeah they were we're cool about
it they like they congratulated me in
school and stuff like that that's kind
of the logic they're like 15 year-old
boys
[Applause]
you just leave a dummy
[Music]